we track all
you know thousands of billionaires
around the world this year you know
there was a record high of over 2 700.
um and i'm part of our wealth team that
tries to track the fortunes of
all these you know billionaires in the
u.s and abroad and and how it's changed
over the last year and mistakes they
hold in all their businesses
most people got richer
[Music]
of the billionaires from last year's
list got you know have a higher net
worth this year
there were almost 500 newcomers a lot
more people that dropped off that return
to the list you know it
kind of contradicted the pain and the
the subframe of a lot of you know the
normal you know unemployment stats that
we've seen in pandemic but
it was a good year for billionaires and
not many drop-offs at all
there were just 61 people uh
billionaires from last year's list that
dropped off this year's list
um and that was the lowest number since
2011 when they were 41 but back then
there were only about a thousand
billionaires about half as many as there
were this year
um so i mean it was really you know by
proportion
you know lowest lower than we've seen in
decades
and you know a lot of that was because
of just the stock market's crazy
recovery like i said
um but you know there there were a few
big names that that that have been in
the news you know like kylie jenner
that we saw that dropped off this year's
list that were on last year
it got a lot of publicity when she made
our list in 2019 and 2020 i think when
um the the filings that her family
showed
reporters and analysts that um led
people to believe that her kylie
cosmetics business
brought in a lot more revenue than it
actually did which was exposed when
about half of it was bought by the
beauty company cody and then it has to
file you know public filings that
actually show what revenue really is
and i think it surprised a lot of people
that that it was lower than what they
were saying so
we had to value her stake a little bit
lower and now she's worth
we have about 700 million dollars so
it's not like she's
really hurting hurting too much but you
know she
she's not on the list anymore but um
like her half sister
kim kardashian actually made the list
for the first time so she dropped below
kim
but you know she she might be back in in
the next few years
you know there were others the west
virginia governor jim justice has a lot
of
uh money in coal mining and and his
green bar
resort that didn't do so well um in the
last year
craig newmark from craigslist uh
craigslist revenue dropped
about 26 last year so he dropped off you
know craigslist revalued by revenue
and as a multiple of for some of its you
know competitors
and its revenue declined 26 last year
because
of you know just more competition from
facebook marketplace and and other
things that
i guess a lot of people are kind of
considering more um
reputable than than than craigslist
or at least you know have the legitimacy
of a big company behind it
um so yeah the craigslist revenue has
kind of declined the last two years and
so his net worth is
has dropped just under a billion dollars
you know last year was a kind of a
special case when we had several hundred
drop off because
you know the list was priced out right
kind of it ended up being right
close to the bottom of where um the
stock market crashed when it was
the the corn values paying down it was
just starting to become a big deal last
march in 2020
and um so you know there weren't many
people that dropped further
down than that where it was you know
last year
but you know i think in the future i
mean you'll you'll probably see some
regression doesn't mean somewhere in the
middle
of this you know years small number of
about 60 versus
last year's a few hundred with you know
the stock market it's unlikely to be
you know almost you know up 70
for another year like it was this year
that's just it doesn't usually happen
most years so
i think over the next year you'll
probably see a few more people to drop
back down
below that threshold as the stock market
kind of levels out and
and stops you know roaring back um
but you know overall i think
you know it's pretty clear that the
trend of the last 20 to 30 years since
we started tracking this is that
in general you know the rich get richer
i think that's that's probably pretty
likely to continue
you